بس عشان ألخصها، أنت أبو سلمان مرة دبلوماسي
وقاعد تعطينا عبارات عامة، بس عشان أفهمها
جهة تعاقدت مع شركة حراسات أمنية، لأنها منخفضة التكلفة
شركة الحراسات الأمنية هذه جابت موظفين كأنهم سعوديين
بس فعليًّا هم ما هم سعوديين، يحملون جنسية عربية
نعم
وسلمتهم المواقع
هذا إذا كانوا يحملون جنسية بعد
بس هنا واحد يشتكي، يقول الضغط علينا كبير
صار لي سنتين مو مسموح لي آخذ إجازة
أنتم بالتأكيد معطينه عقد وفي العقد حقه إجازة
بس ضاغطينه لدرجة أن هو ما يقدر ياخذ إجازة
فكيف تعلّق على هذا؟
هو الضغط اللي حاصل من الإدارة التنفيذية الآن
أنهم يطلعون  إجازة
عجيب! أنتم من الوحيدين اللي عندكم رخصة حمل سلاح؟ موظفينكم؟
أنا بعطيك أكبر دليل
إيه
أي شركة تعمل في النقل المؤتمن يجب أن تحمل سلاح
«سيف» أو غير «سيف»
غير النقل المؤتمن؟
غير النقل المؤتمن إذا اعتمدت وزارة الداخلية
الموقع أن يكون موقع حماية مسلّح
سيكون متوفر لـ «سيف» وغير «سيف»
بس فيه سؤال صريح، هل فيه أحد غيركم عنده رخصة حمل سلاح؟
هذا سقراط من إذاعة ثمانية، وأنا عمر الجريسي
أستضيف قادة التحول وقادة الأعمال وقادة الرأي
ضيف حلقة اليوم هو الأستاذ «تركي بن معتوق الثنيان»
الرئيس التنفيذي للشركة الوطنية للخدمات الأمنية «سيف»
إحدى شركات صندوق الاستثمارات العامة
من الشركات الجديدة اللي لما تأسست
كان فيه تساؤل ليش صندوق سيادي استثماري
يدخل في قطاع تفصيلي مثل قطاع الحراسات الأمنية
ففي بداية الحلقة سولفنا عن واقع القطاع
وأيش أبرز التحديات والفجوات اللي موجودة فيه
ليش الشركة تأسست في هذا القطاع؟
أيش الفرق بينها وبين اللي موجود في السوق؟
من حيث مزايا الموظفين، تأهيلهم، تدريبهم
ليش فيه 300 ألف شخص مقدم على الشركة
وموجود في قوائم انتظارها؟
تكلمنا على موضوع التدريب اللي يقدم لهم
تكلمنا عن دورهم في دعم الشركات الأخرى اللي موجودة في السوق
هل هو دعم أو منافسة؟
هل لأنهم مملكين من الصندوق عندهم مزايا إضافية
في الحصول على عقود مع شركات الصندوق الأخرى؟
ليش ما حصلوا على عقد مع «البوليفارد» أو شركة «صلة»
اللي تدير وتشغّل «بوليفارد الرياض» أو «بوليفارد سيتي»
بعد كذا ختمنا بمجموعة من أسئلة الأصدقاء
اللي يغلب عليها أسئلة الموظفين
موظفين شركة «سيف» وحراس الأمن
مثل عدم وجود مظلات أو أماكن استراحة
في جدة «البلد» لموظفين شركة «سيف»
وجود ربط أو التزام ثمان ساعات بدون أي حركة في بعض المناطق النائية
ووجود حسميات أحيانًا حادة وأكثر من المعتاد في موضوع الغياب
وغيرها من أسئلة الأصدقاء الثمينة
هذه أسئلة موظفين «سيف» وحراس الأمن
بالإضافة طبعًا للأسئلة العامة المتعلقة
بأنهم هل بيدخلون في مجال المرور؟
هل بيدخلون في أمن المطارات؟
إلى آخر أسئلتكم الثمينة
شكرًا للراعي الرسمي شركة «صفا» للاستثمار
أترككم مع الحوار
حياك الله أبو سلمان، شرفتنا ونورتنا
الله يطول عمرك، وشاكر لاستضافتك
أبو سلمان، ونحن نجمع معلومات عنك
عادةً نبدأ الحلقة بسؤال شخصي أو سؤال عن معلومة
تخص هواية أو اهتمام أو نمط حياة معين
فوحدة المعلومات اللي لقيناها عنك
أن واحد قال هو شخص لا ينام إلا عند الحاجة
فالمعلومة غريبة، ما أدري احنا ننام لما نعطش مثلًا
كلنا ننام عند الحاجة
لا أعتقد أن هو يقصد بشكل غير مباشر أن أنا ما أنام
قليل النوم مرة
هو قليل النوم، أعتقد هذا أحد من الفريق التنفيذي في الشركة، ليش؟
لأن الإيميلات تجي، أنا ما أطالبهم بأن يعملوا خارج أوقات الدوام
ولكن إيميلات يجي الصباح يشوفها
فبيشوف إيميل مثلًا منتصف الليل، بيشوف إيميل بعد صلاة الفجر
بيشوف إيميل في المغرب، فهو يمكن هذا اللي...
يحاول يشوف متى نام هذا الرجال، ما يلقى وقت نوم
هو قاعد يسأل مو عن النوم، قاعد يسأل حاجة، متى تجيه الحاجة
كم ساعة أنت في اليوم تنام؟
في الأسبوع أوقات العمل في الغالب النوم قليل جدًّا
قليل وللا متقطع؟
لا، قليل
كم ساعة في اليوم؟ ثلاث ساعات أو أربع ساعات؟
تقريبًا ثلاث أو أربع ساعات
هو اليوم اللي يكون فيه النوم بشكل جيد يوم الجمعة فقط
يوم الجمعة
يوم السبت تحضير للأسبوع
ما في آثار سلبية؟ ترى هذه تراكمية، أتوقع بترك أثر على الصحة
اليوم الواحد في شبابه وقوته فالجسم يتحمل
بس أن أثرها يبقى لاحقًّا
صحيح، فهو اجتمعت الأسباب
الكيان يستحق والوطن يستحق
إضافةً إلى أن هذه شركة ناشئة
فالشركة ناشئة معدلات النجاح إن لم يكن نمط العاملين
في الفريق بالشكل هذا
لأن معروف أن معدلات نجاح الشركات الناشئة ماهي عالية
فإذا سألت ماذا تحتاج الشركات الناشئة؟
تحتاج من يعي أيش معناه شركة ناشئة، مسؤولية، أعداد كبيرة
عندك وقت تشوف مشاكل الموظفين من قنواتك الخاصة
عندك وقت تفكر في مشاكل معقدة على أساس أن تحلها
وتساعد زملائك
عندك وقت تعالج بعض الإشكاليات
مع الجهات الموجودة في المنظومة أو النظام البيئي حق القطاع
واحنا اليوم على طاري الشركة الناشئة
احنا اليوم سعداء نستضيفك أبو سلمان
بصفتك قائد شركة ناشئة، ناشئة كمسمى
بس كحجم وكعمليات هي شركة ضخمة
اللي هي الشركة الوطنية للخدمات الأمنية «سيف»
أنت تقودها من فبراير 2020، صحيح؟
15 فبراير 2020 إلى اليوم
فيمكن في كل مرة يُطرح موضوع صندوق الاستثمارات العامة
وتأسيسه لشركات في قطاعات ماهي استراتيجية من وجهة نظر الناس
دائما يضرب المثال بشركة «سيف»
تخيلوا الصندوق حتى في حراسات أمنية مسوي شركة
ليش الصندوق السيادي أسس شركة في قطاع الخدمات الأمنية؟
خلينا نتفق على نقاط
النقطة الوحيدة، قطاع غير استراتيجي
هذا تحتاج أن ننظر في الموضوع بشكل جيد
الأمن يعتبر شيء استراتيجي في كل مكان
الحمد لله، نجاح الجهات المختصة في الموضوع هذا
ممكن أن هو قلل توقعات المجتمع من الشركات في القطاع الأمني
الحاجة الثانية أن «سيف» منافس
لما نقول احنا «سيف» منافس؛ معناته هناك ما يقارن به
لكن لما نجي نشوف استراتيجية «سيف»
نجي نشوف الأهداف الاستراتيجية لـ«سيف»
نجي نشوف نموذج العمل، نجي نشوف رحلة العميل
فهي كلها مختلفة بشكل كبير عما يفتقده السوق
الآن لو سألنا، هل هناك معهد تدريب معتمد للخدمات الأمنية غير «سيف»؟
ما في
السؤال الآخر، هل يوجد هنالك خدمات مراكز تحكم تقدم كدعم؟
مراكز تحكم
مراكز تحكم متخصصة...
لا بد أن يكون هنالك وضعية مفهومة لمركز التحكم
مركز التحكم هو التشغيل وليس الشاشات
ففيه ممكن واحد يقول لك هذا مركز تحكم
لكن ماذا يحصل داخل مركز التحكم؟
نجي بعدين على موضوع الخدمات الاستشارية
مثلًا يجيك عميل ما يعرف الخدمة الأمنية
فأنا هذا رحلة العميل حقه، يقول لك
أنا أحتاج أمن وللا ما أحتاج أمن؟
طبيعة الأمن اللي أنا أحتاجها
فأنت قاعد تغير النموذج حق السوق
من مبني على أصول وأعداد وكمي إلى مبني على معايير أداء وجودة
تنتقل بعد ذلك على تطوير الحلول
في كثير من الأحيان جزء من الخلل اللي حاصل
أن فيه شركات تبيعك التقنية، وفيه شركات تقدم خدمات
فالكل في الجهتين هذه هو عنده رغبة كبيرة في البيع
لكن لما تدمج الثنتين هذه، فتذهب أنت إلى إيجاد حلول
فالبيع راح تحل المشاكل حق العميل
في التسويق راح تحل المشاكل اللي ما يدري عنها العميل أنها موجودة عنده
فنموذج العمل بشكل كامل غير موجود
نتكلم فكرة «سيف» ماهي وليدة اللحظة
ترى لها سنين طويلة الموضوع
كيف ننشئ قطاع يمكن الاعتماد عليه
كداعم في القطاع الخاص للجهات المختصة؟
بسّطها يا أبو سلمان، نبيها بدون العبارات الرسمية
ممتاز، نبسطها بالعملية الأمنية، هي ما هي بالشكل هذا
ولكن العملية الأمنية مكونة من خمس أو أربع خطوات
هي عبارة عن رصد، توثيق، تبليغ، تقييم، واستجابة
الأربع خطوات الأولى هذه، القطاع الخاص يستطيع أن يحصل عليها
أكبر مثال عندنا في أنظمة المرور المتكامل
ما تحتاج دورية، ولا تحتاج رجل أمن
تلتقط المخالفة، وتلغي الاحتكاك اللي يحصل ما بين شخصين
هذه الخدمات كلها طبقها على المدن الذكية
طبقها على المواقف الذكية، طبقها على التحكم في الوصول
طبقها على المطارات، كل القطاعات هذه يستطيع
نتكلم عن المطارات، هناك أكثر من 173 مطار في أوربا في قطاع خاص
ما يقوم فيه القطاع العام أو الجهات المختصة هي الاستجابة
اللي هي آخر مرحلة وآخر فقرة
الشنطة داخلها في الأشعة، فيه شيء مشبوه
يتكلمون مع الجمارك أو مكافحة المخدرات
الجهة المختصة وهذا يسمونه استجابة
حتى في بعض الأحيان، الاستجابة يتدخل فيها القطاع الخاص
برقابة معينة يسمونها بروتوكولات التواصل
لما تصير القضية الدرجة حقها بالشكل هذا؛ توجّه
من ناحية أخرى؛ نعمل
احنا للأسف عندنا الفقرة الأخيرة، اللي هي الاستجابة
اللي منتظرة من الجهات الرسمية توسعت
وصرنا نشوف الجهات الرسمية السيادية
اللي دورها مهم ومقدر؛ قاعدة تُشغل بأدوار أحيانًا ماهي مفهومة
ليش جهاز عسكري سيادي قاعد يحرس مجمّع وللا يحمي مجمّع
يمكن هذا جزء من عدم وجود لاعبين متمكنين
في القطاع الخاص يقومون بهذا الدور
صحيح، وأنا أرجع وأقول لك هو علامة نجاح، ليش؟
لأن التحول كان سريع جدًّا؛ مما أدى أن لازم القطاع هذا يلتحق بالتحول
فهو علامة تطور، لأن فيه تطور سريع حاصل
مما أدى الاستعانة بالجهات المختصة
تؤدي عمل غير العمل اللي هي مؤهلة له، لأن مافي فرصة للإنشاء
وخلال الوقت هذا وضع في الاعتبار
أن لا بد أن يكون هناك لاعب رئيسي في السوق
من بداية الفكرة إلى عام 2019
ولكن نظرًا لإتساع الفجوة أصبح لا بد منه
ودامنا بنسولف عن الفكرة، أنا بقتبس كلام
لمعالي «ياسر الريان» اللي كان ضيفنا في سقراط
قال لما أنشأنا المجلس التأسيسي لشركة «سيف»
قالوا لنا الفكرة سيئة، هذا رأي المجلس التأسيسي لشركة «سيف»
وعدلنا، وبعد كم شهر ما زال المجلس التأسيسي يرى أنها فكرة سيئة
فالإدارة قررت بأنها تلغي المجلس التأسيسي
وتأخذ الفكرة داخل صندوق الاستثمارات العامة
وتطورها وتشتغل عليها وتنفذها
رغم أن المجلس التأسيسي كان يشوف أنها فكرة سيئة
لو تحدثني على مراحل تأسيس الشركات
في صندوق الاستثمارات العامة بشكل عام
قبلما ندخل تحديدًا لهذه الشركة
أيش دور المجلس التأسيسي؟
أيش الفكرة من إلغاءه وتنفيذ الفكرة؟
رغم أنه كان يرى أنها فكرة غير جيدة؟
والله صندوق الاستثمارات العامة من الاسم
هو يفكر في المشروع من ناحية استثمارية ودراسة جدوى
ولكن أنا أنظر لها من جهة الفكرة
وجود إصرار من المعالي؛ وضع علينا مسؤولية أن نجعلها مثال ناجح
واللقاء اللي حصل فيه الكلام هذا، كان كجرعة منشطة للمواصلة
فأنا أتكلم عن «سيف»
«سيف» دائمًا ترى أن ما ذُكر هو مسؤولية كبيرة
يجب أن نثبت صحة الاستثمار في القطاع هذا
لأن من خلال الوقت اللي راح هذا كله
المستثمرين أنفسهم اللي يستثمرون بشكل مؤسسي
اتجهوا إلى قطاعات أكثر ربحية وأكثر أمنًا
طيب إذا ترُك القطاع هذا بالشكل هذا، أيش اللي بيحصل؟
أنا متأكد أن الجهات المختصة ما أُغفلوا عن الموضوع هذا
بس أيش كانت الدوافع؟ ليش نحتاج نسوي الشركة؟
أنت ذكرت مجموعة منها، أن القطاع يفتقد لموضوع مراكز تدريب
شركات متخصصة في الاستشارات إلى آخره
أيش فيه أيضًا مشاكل أخرى في القطاع
دفعت الصندوق أن يصر ويتبنى فكرة تأسيس هذه الشركة؟
أيش فيه مشاكل أخرى؟
أول عبارة لازم أن أقولها: أصبح القطاع هذا واجهة وطن
أنت عندك سياحة، عندك مناسبات
عندك دور ريادي تقوم فيه المملكة
فيه زوار يجونا المملكة، أول من يشاهدون، يشاهدون مين؟
قطاع الخدمات الأمنية
الإنسان لما يوصل المملكة في المطار، يبحث عن أيش؟
يبحث عن أقصى سرعة في الخروج
ولما يجي بشكل مبكر في المطار، يبغى يستنى في المطار
التحكم في الوصول والعملية الأمنية هذه جزء منها كبير
الفعاليات اللي تقوم فيها السياحة والثقافة وإدارة الفعاليات والمناسبات
هذه فيه دور كبير
واحنا شفنا أظن حالة في بداية انطلاقة الفعاليات الترفيهية
صحيح
كان فيه حالة لأعتقد 2017 كانت أو 2016
أكثر من حالة، ولكن الحمد لله
كان فيه اعتداء
ورغم أن الفعالية كانت فيها شركة تنظيم
صحيح، وهذا هو المطلب
أنا لما أجي أطلب شركة تنظيم، ويجوني أشخاص
مع كل الود والاحترام والتقدير، أنا أتكلم عن شريحة معينة
ما أتكلم عن جميع الشركات
اليوم عندنا عمل، التكلفة حقته اليومية
مين يبي بيشتغل معنا في العمل هذا
ممكن يكون جزء من العاملين في العمل هذا
هو التهديد غير التهديد الخارجي
نجي بعدين على موضوع مستحقات العاملين في القطاع هذا
أنت تسألني كيف نظرت «سيف» للمنظومة؟
نظرت «سيف» للمنظومة من العاملين في القطاع
ومزودين خدمة في القطاع والجهات التشريعية والعملاء
بدايةً بالعاملين في القطاع
كان الهدف الأساسي تجديد هوية رجل الأمن
نحن ما نبغى نتحدث عن الهوية السابقة
لا، ودي أتحدث عنها، لأنها جزء من التحدي
جزء من مشكلة القطاع هذا؛ أن مجموعة من العاملين فيه
لا يتم تدريبهم أو اعطاهم، لأن في النهاية تقوله ما أدى أداء جيد
وأنت ما أعطيته التدريب الكافي
وهذا من حقه أن يحصل على تدريب جيد
صحيح
لا يستقطبون بالشكل الصحيح
وفي حالات أنا انصدمت أن ما هم سعوديين أصلًا
وإن كان مظهروه سعودي بس ماهم سعوديين
وأنت الظاهر عندك قصة أنكم مسكتوا حراس الأمن
اللي كانوا في الموقع
أنا ما أدري من وين قاعد تجيب المعلومات
أنا ودي أسمع القصة هذه، لأنها طبعًا لا تعبر عن كل اللي في السوق
فيه ناس والنعم، وفيه شركات والنعم
بس أقصد فيه حالات تم فيها اختراق المهنة هذه
اللي هي مهنة حساسة، وعملوا فيها ناس ما هم سعوديين
نرجع للسؤال، عندما يكون هدفك ربحي بحت في العمل هذا؛ هذه النتيجة
عطنا السالفة هذه، أيش قصة الموظفين؟
هو احنا كنا نعمل في منطقة معينة نقوم بحمايتها
أحد مزودين الخدمة في المنطقة
في وجهة نظره تعتبر «سيف» عالية التكاليف عليه
اختار شركة، طبعًا لما يكون اختيار الشركة أو مزود خدمة
بناءً على التكلفة؛ ما راح يقوم بالفحص النافي للجهالة
الفحص النافي للجهالة
أيوة، الفحص النافي للجهالة
هناك متطلبات وضعتها الجهات المختصة يجب الالتزام فيها
تم التزويد بالخدمة
الجهات المختصة من وقت إلى آخر تقوم بمعاينة المواقع
في الفترة هذيك، كان هناك حاجة لمعاينة بعض المواقع
كان أول الخارجين من الموقع، موظفين...
شركة الحراسات الأمنية هذه، كانت موظفة ناس
واتضح أنهم ما هم سعوديين
ما هم سعوديين وبرضه غير...
وعندهم سوابق وعندهم مشاكل
فكان جزء من «سيف»
فأول من هجم الموقع هم
وجزء من مساندة «سيف» كانت مساندة الجهات المختصة للقبض عليهم
وهذولي طبعًا كانوا مسجلين وكأنهم سعوديين
مافي تسجيل
هو بالنسبة لمزود الخدمة يبي يشوف الأفراد ويدفع للشركة
بس عشان ألخصها، أنت أبو سلمان مرة دبلوماسي
وقاعد تعطينا عبارات عامة، بس عشان أفهمها
جهة تعاقدت مع شركة حراسات أمنية، لأنها منخفضة التكلفة
نعم
شركة الحراسات الأمنية هذه جابت موظفين كأنهم سعوديين
بس فعليًّا هم ما هم سعوديين، يحملون جنسية عربية
وسلمتهم المواقع
هذا أن كانوا يحملون جنسية بعد
إن كانوا، وجاوا للموقع
ممكن يكونوا متخلفين أو متسللين أو عابري الحدود
ممكن
جيتوا أنتم ومسكتوا حراس الأمن هذولا، لأنهم كانوا بينحاشون من الموقع
احنا ما مسكناهم، كان فيه دور للجهات المختصة في المنطقة
وكان خروجهم ملفت
فاللي كنا نبي نحرسهم طلعوا هم...
اللي كانوا يقدمون الخدمة ذيك كانوا ما هم...
فهذا مجرد مثال على كيف أن القطاع...
وهذا طبعًا لا يعمم
لا تعمم نهائيًّا
لكن هذه النماذج موجودة في عملية الاستقطاب، وهذه مشكلة
ومشكلة ثانية، ذكر حتى معالي «الريان» في الحلقة
موضوع الرواتب، موظفين الحراسات الأمنية
متعارف عليه أن رواتبهم جدًّا جدًّا متدنية، هذا إن حصلوا عليها
فلو تحدثنا عن هذه المشكلة برضه
أوه! يبدو لي التحضير جدًّا رائع للحلقة
هذا إن حصلوا عليها هذا يدلل على أنه...
مخمخين احنا
أنا خلني أقول لك، لما يجيك شخص يبحث عن وظيفة متدنية
أنت تتكلم عن مكتب لتأجير السيارات مثلا يعطي راتب معين
أيش يخلي الإنسان يترك المكتب هذا
ويعمل في ظروف جوية صعبة ومواجهة جمهور
براتب يعتبر نصف هذا الراتب أو ربعه؟
ليش؟
لأنه ما قدر بمؤهلاته أن يأخذ الوظيفة هذه
أول شيء عملته «سيف» اكتساب ولاء الموظف للمهنة هذه
فأنت تعطي الموظف راتب مناسب، بيئة مناسبة
إدارة مناسبة؛ سيصبح جاذب
أول نجاح، الحمد لله، وفقنا الله فيه أن بيئة العمل أصبحت جاذب
الآن المنصة، عدد الموظفين ما يقارب 9000 اليوم، آخر إحصائية 8500
بس آخر تحديث أمس في المشاريع ممكن نوصل لـ 9000 وقت الحلقة
9000 موظف يعملون في «سيف»
نعم، على مستوى ثمانية وثلاثين محافظة، ثلاث دول تعمل فيها
استقطاب موظفين 8500 لـ 9000 تتكلم في الجهة المقابلة
الوظيفة هذه كانت مرفوضة
الآن عندنا في المنصة أكثر من 300 ألف متقدم
كم؟
300 ألف متقدم
300 ألف متقدم على قوائم الانتظار
نعم،
ليش؟
راتب مناسب، حقوق
كم الرواتب عندكم؟
مجازفةً بقول لك 5500
بس الراتب أنا اللي أعرفه 6000 أقل حد أدنى للموظف
في السوق هذه المهنة عادة كم يعطونها؟
أتذكر 2500 - 3000، صح؟
صحيح
هذا اللي عادةً في السوق لهذه المهن
هو يعتمد برضه على العميل، لأن بدأ العميل يتنبه
بعد ما دخلت «سيف» السوق شاف الموضوع فلقى أن...
لو العميل هو بادر وحط حد أدنى للرواتب
فصار يضع في العقد هو حد أدنى للرواتب
هذا جزء من إضافات اللي أضافته «سيف»
لأن لما الناس بدأت تشوف الخدمة مختلفة
ما بين «سيف» والآخرين بدأوا يسألون
فأنا أعتقد أن حتى الموضوع هذا
هذه حقوق الموظفين، ما المفروض أنك...
نحن ما زلنا بس نحصر تحديات القطاع
قبلما ندخل لأيش الشيء اللي أنتم قدمتوه
وحدة من التحديات اللي برضه سولفنا عنها أنا وياك أبو سلمان
هي موضوع المسؤولية
أنت كنت تتكلم على أن أغلب الشركات اللي موجودة في القطاع اليوم
القدرة على تحميلها المسؤولية تكاد تكون معدومة
لو توضح لنا هذا الموضوع
هي بشكل تجاري، أنت عندك مؤسسة وعندك شركة وعندك مستقلين
وكل هذه مسؤولياتها محدودة
لكن لما تجيك شركة تستطيع أن تحيل المسؤولية كلها عليها
في أسوأ الاحتمالات، إذا صار أنت ماسك مناسبة جدًّا كبيرة
أو ملتقى جدًّا كبير، وحصل خلل أمني
المسؤولية حقته عالية، ولكن إلى أي مدى بتنتقل؟
إلى مدى إن الشركة تقفل
فاحنا كل يوم بتجينا تساؤلات من جهات مختصة
ومن سلطات عليا، ليش؟
لأن المسؤولية موجودة، الكيان هذا قائم وسيستمر ويجب أن يكون
سامحني ما وصلت لي، ممكن توضحها أكثر
أيش المشكلة في الشركات الحالية؟ وكيف أنتم معالجتوها؟
الشركات الحالية ما يوجد فيها مشكلة
بعض الشركات اللي يوجد فيها مشكلة
مثلًا لنفترض كان هناك ما تم فقده يقدّر بـ 500 ألف
جاء العميل يطالب بحقه
العميل اللي هو صاحب المنشأة مستعين بشركة حراسات
فقد 500 ألف، يبي ياخذ حقه
أكيد أنه بيلجأ للجهات المختصة، فيه مسؤولية محدودة
ممكن المسؤولية المحدودة هذه ما تتجاوز؛ فصار فيه خسارة للعميل
راعي الحراسات الأمنية يقفل الشركة ويقول أبد، ما لكم عندي شيء
ممكن يكون الموضوع هذا كجزء بسيط
لكن في موضوع مثل «سيف» ما أعتقد أن في يوم من الأيام...
نحن بالعكس، فيه بعض شركاءنا وعملائنا يمرون بمناسبات
ويمرون في تحديات، ونحن نطرح موارد إضافية على الموقع
بناءً على رؤيتنا دون الرجوع لهم
وهذه ممكن تلخص أهم التحديات أو الفجوات اللي في القطاع
واللي «سيف» جاية تحاول تغطيها
اليوم خلنا نتكلم عن كيف تعاملت «سيف» مع هذه الفجوات
وأيش المختلف فيها
تكلمنا عن الرواتب وغطيناها
أبغى الآن تسولف لي عن موضوع الاستقطاب
اشتراطات الاستقطاب، الفحص اللي أنتم تسوونه
أو أي متطلبات تسوونها
وأيش فرقتم اليوم عن اللي موجود في السوق
أول شيء، الحمد لله، نجحنا في خلق منظومة داخل منظومة
فهناك متطلبات من الشركات الأمنية لتوظيف العاملين في القطاع
وهناك متطلبات للجهات المختصة
التي يجب أن يلتزم فيها الشركات والمؤسسات للعمل في القطاع
وهنالك متطلبات لـ«سيف»
فنجي لمتطلبات الشركات الحالية
هي المتطلبات اللي احنا ذكرناها في حوارنا السابق
متطلبات وزارة الداخلية هي عبارة عن فحص السموم
صحيفة السوابق، أضف إلى ذلك السيرة
طيب نجي لمتطلبات «سيف»
متطلبات «سيف» تتحدث عن إضافة متطلبات
مثل الوزن، الطول، إضافة المتطلبات السابقة، تجاوز المقابلة
يتم عقد مقابلتين، مقابلة مع إدارة الموارد البشرية داخل الشركة
وإدارة العمليات يتم المقابلة بعد ذلك
السؤال، ليش كل هذه المقابلات في وظيفة بالشكل هذا؟
هذا واجهة وطن، واجهة كيان، واجهة أي منشأة يعمل فيها
فمن اللازم أن يتم اختياره بشكل جيد
بعد الاختيار هذا كله، يتم التدريب
والتدريب اللي حاصل له قصة كاملة كيف يتم التدريب
عطني إياها، أيش فرق معاكم بموضوع التدريب؟
أول حاجة، أن العامل في القطاع بدأ يعرف أيش أساسيات العمل الأمني
«سيف» كانت تبحث عن طريقة منهجية للتدريب
كانت تستطيع تقول والله احنا ندرب، نحضر مدربين وندرب
ولكن هذه المصداقية كيف أن أنت تطورها
تعاوننا مع جهات عالمية، تم الاعتراف في شهادات معينة
احنا ما نقدم تدريب فقط، نقدم شهادة
ليست حضور دورة، ولكن اجتياز امتحان
طبعًا النجاح اللي حصل في العملية هذه
أن احنا نجحنا من خلال أحد المنظمات الدولية
اللي استمرت أكثر من أربعين سنة تقدم التدريب باللغة الإنجليزية
نجحنا في أن احنا نضمن عدد متدربين معين
على أن يتم تحويل المنهج باللغة العربية، ويتم الاختبار باللغة العربية
هذا التدريب كل الموظفين يمرون عليه في البداية؟
هذا التدريب يمر على كل الموظفين
احنا طبعًا أنشأنا برضه منهج على أساس نقلل من الصعوبات
موظف الحماية الوطنية هذا مسار اعتمدناه
هذا المسار الجميل فيه أنه يعتبر أهم من المسار الأساسي، ليش؟
لأن فيه نظرنا للتشريعات، نظرنا للتميز، ما يميز الثقافة عندنا
نظرنا إلى الاحتياجات المتطلبة؛ وبعد كذا تم تطوير المنهج وتم اعتماده
إضافة إلى ما تم تعريبه
نجاح التعريب هذا ليس للمملكة العربية السعودية وليس للخليج
الوطن العربي كله يستطيع الآن
طبعًا هي اللغة الوحيدة إذا ما خانتني الذاكرة إذا كان هناك إسبانية
ولكن أعتقد هي اللغة الوحيدة
في «المؤسسة الدولية لمسؤولي الحماية» اللي تم تحويلها
فهذا عمل...
بس الموظف كم يأخذ من دورة عندكم؟
الموظف أول ما يتوظف إضافة إلى المقابلات
ياخذ دورة في حدود أسبوع إلى أسبوعين
بعد كذا يأخذ دورة ثانية على التدريب الوظيفي، اللي هي...
لأن كل بيئة عمل مختلفة
فيروح للميدان ويسأل المشرف
ويشرح له أن هذا أداء عملك وهذا كذا وكذا
بعد كذا يبدأ المشرف يتابع الأعمال حقته
عمر الشركة ماهو طويل، الآن انتقلنا إلى مرحلة أخرى
من الشباب هذولا تم استقطاب عدد معين من الكوادر الأمنية
للمراحل الإشرافية
بعد كذا فيه مسار آخر، مسار التخصص
لأن شركة «سيف» مستهدفة
على أساس هذا الموضوع ضروري أن نحن نقوله
أنت عندك في السوق أكثر من خمسة وعشرين قطاع أمني
«سيف» تستهدف كل القطاعات
ولكن تركيزها في ست قطاعات
قطاع النقل والطيران، قطاع الخدمات البنكية
قطاع المنشآت الحيوية، قطاع المنشآت الصناعية
قطاع حماية الشخصيات والمناسبات والقطاع الحكومي
طبعًا نحن نعرّج الآن على الأهداف الاستراتيجية
نحن في البداية قلنا أهدافنا
بس ما انسألنا كيف يختلف الموضوع؟
احنا كاستراتيجية؛ الاستراتيجيات كلها تنحصر ما بين ثلاث استراتيجيات
يا نمو، يا تميز، يا تكلفة
فما كان فيه مزود خدمة في السوق يبحث على التميز في الخدمة
كان أكثرهم التكلفة
حتى العملاء ثلاثة أنواع: عميل التكلفة
وعميل يبحث عن دعم، وعميل يبحث عن جودة، وهناك اختلاف
التكلفة يقول لك أنا مطالب مني، وأنا ما أرى أن فيه قيمة مضافة
الدعم يقول لك إذا حصلت مشكلة أحتاج إدارة، بس ما أحتاج...
الجودة يقول لك خذ القطاع هذا من داخل المنشأة؛ أنت اهتم فيه
فهذا كإستراتيجية لدى «سيف»
وهذا كان نحتاج يكون فيه بديل
انتقلنا بعدين على أيش الأهداف الاستراتيجية
أول هدف، الارتقاء بقطاع الخدمات الأمنية في المنطقة
ثاني هدف، تعزيز التكامل ما بين عناصر العملية الأمنية
وهذه نسميها « 3 بي» اللي هي العنصر البشري
والعنصر التقني والعنصر الإجرائي
فكل الشركات اللي موجودة تعمل بشكل منفصل
فهذا أثّر على رحلة العميل
ما كان يقدر يجي عميل يقول كم أحتاج لرجل الأمن من شركة استشارية
لازم يروح لشركة استشارية أو يروح للشركة الأمنية
والشركة الأمنية طبعًا تقول لك العدد هذا على حسب
لا، الآن العميل يستطيع أن يجي يقول لك
أنا بطرح مناقصة، أيش المتطلبات؟
يجي يقول أيش الأفضل؟
يجي يقول هل أنا مفروض أن أعتمد على العنصر البشري؟
وللا هناك تقنيات تمكنني أن أكون بالشكل هذا؟
يجي ويقول هل ممكن أن أستفيد من التقنيات هذه في أمور أخرى؟
إدارة أسطول، عد، إدارة حشود؟
مع أن نفس التقنيات هذه تقنيان أمنية، فهذا تعزيز التكامل
الجزء الثالث، الهدف الاستراتيجي هو دعم المبادرات الأمنية
لخصخصة الخدمات الأمنية
وهذا احنا تحدثنا عنه في بداية الحديث أن هنالك رغبة
الاستثمار في الاستجابة في القطاعات الأمنية يعتبر مكلف
لأن فيه تدريب على السلاح وفيه تدريب على الاشتباك
ولكن يجب أن يتناسب الاستثمار مع الحاجة
فإذا أعطينا كل جهة تركيز على الخدمة الأساسية عندها
بعد كذا راح يكون فيه جودة
بقدر أركز أنا في خدمتي الأمنية
على جانب أن يكون «سيف» بيئة آمنة ومرحبة
بس ما أكون عندي الاستعداد اللي ممكن يكون ملفت أن فيه إشكالية
بعد كذا تأثر نموذج العمل، عندنا أربعة خطوط أعمال
التشاور والمشورة، وهذا اللي دائمًا ننصح عملاءنا
هل نقدر نقولها بالعربي؟
المعذرة، اللي هي إدارة الاستشارات الأمنية
وإدارة مراكز التحكم وإدارة التدريب والتطوير وإدارة الحلول
بعد ما عملنا بالشكل هذا
لقينا أن احنا عندنا تكامل مع مكافحة الحرائق والسلامة وإدارة المرافق
وهذا ما يميز «سيف»
لأن أنت قاعد تساعد العميل برضه أن ياخذ خدمة متكاملة
فخليني أعطيك إياها على سبيل مثال
الصرافة فيها عملية أمنية اللي هي تغيير الكاسيت اللي فيها النقد
الآن أنت تساعد العميل أن يأخذ الخدمة متكاملة
إذا قدمت خدمة إدارة مرافق في تنظيف الصرافة
صيانة الصرافة، صيانة الإضاءة والمكيف
بعد كذا العميلة الأمنية
فسويت مثل الخدمات المتكاملة
هذا جزء برضه من دورنا
أنا اللي قاعد أقوله في بداية حديثنا منافس
ماهو موجود النموذج ذا، نموذج العمل هذا غير موجود هناك
طيب وين شراكة الكيانات الأخرى؟ يستطيعون يقدمون
أنا أجي أصير مقدم الخدمة بالكامل، وهو يستطيع أن يقدّم
في السابق قلت لك قاعد تعطيه تدريب
فبعد ما فتحنا التدريب الحين للمجتمع
لأن أصبح ردة فعل المجتمع أكثر من ردة فعل الشركات
فهي «سيف» عبارة محفّز لخلق مسارات جديدة
والتحول بما يتواكب مع المستقبل والرؤية في المنظومة طبعًا
صحيح، وهذا، جزاك الله خير، تعريف جيد على موضوع الأهداف
والقطاعات اللي أنتم شغالين فيها
بس أنا برجع أقفل موضوع العنصر البشري
لأن يمكن هو من أهم الفوارق اللي موجودة عندكم، موضوع التدريب
من الأسئلة اللي جاتنا من الأصدقاء
سؤال على موضوع في بدايات الشركة
كان التدريب يتم من خلال «أرامكو» وكانت الدورة شهر
لما انتقل التدريب لكم اختصرتوها في أسبوع أو أسبوعين
هل هذا اختزال مخل عشان بس توفرون الوقت والتكلفة
قاعدين تضغطون الأمور؟
وللا أنتوا وجدتوا شيء «أرامكو» تقدمه قد ما تحتاجونه؟
«أرامكو» لها معايير صناعية
هم يعملون في مجال الغاز والبترول، والمعايير جدًّا عالية
لكن احنا اللي قاعدين نقدمه، احنا ما نقدم للقطاع الصناعي فقط
على حسب الست قطاعات اللي قلناها؛ فتتراوح الحاجة
فمن الطبيعي أن لا يختزل التدريب
ولكن يقسم إلى تدريب أساسي
وهذا الجميع يحصل عليه وهذا الحاصل الآن
تدريب مختص وهذا على حسب الاتجاهات
وتدريب إشرافي
بعد كذا راح يكون تدريب قيادي لأي قطاع
تلتقي القطاعات في القيادة والإدارة
ولكن هذه الثلاث تدريبات الأساسية
في دورة «أرامكو» كانت مركزة على القطاع الصناعي
وسوّينا فيها بعض الصناعات
لأن لو تروح تشوف الموضوع في «أرامكو»
المدة أكبر، الاعتبارات أكثر، لأن «أرامكو» منظومة
فهم حتى يعلمون رجال الأمن كيف يتعاملون مع المنظومة
وهذه المنظومة ماهي موجودة عندي أنا، فلذلك تم النظر فيها
تكلمنا على موضوع العقد ومحتويات العقد اللي بينكم وبين الموظف
وكنتوا تذكرون على مجموعة فروق بين عقودكم
والعقود السائدة في السوق، أيش أهم الفروقات؟
احنا قلنا الراتب وحكينا على الراتب، أيش غيره؟
العقد فيه ميزة نافسية أخرى وهي اللي خلت الشركة جذابة
طبعًا احنا لما نقول جذابة، احنا نبغى المهنة تكون جاذبة
الأمان الوظيفي، الموظف خُلق له مسار في الشركة
وعلاقته في الشركة هي علاقة مع الشركة مباشرة
وليس علاقة مع المشروع
ما يحدث في السوق الآن بعد انتهاء المشروع؛ يفقد الموظف وظيفته
هذا ما يحصل في «سيف»
فأنتم موظفينكم موظفين «سيف» وليس موظفين مشروع
نعم
بينما الشركات الأخرى مربوطة بالمشروع
أول ما ينتهي المشروع؛ ينتهي عقده
صحيح، على أساس يتفادى التكلفة
هي منظور استثماري، ما في له ما ينص أنه سينتهي عقده
ولكن يقول لك أنا ما أقدر
فأنا بالنسبة لي ما يصبح مشكلته، هذه ماهي مشكلته
هذه مشكلة في القسم التجاري عندي
والتشغيل عندي برضه يعمل بشكل أنه يقدر
احنا عندنا خطة إستجابة عند حدوث مثل هذا الشيء
لدى أحد العملاء ويكون عدد كبير، فيتم إعادة...
فثاني ميزة، أن عقودكم الموظف بيكون اثنا عشر شهر ضامن دخله
على عكس...
مربوط بشكل أساسي بأداؤه
لأن طبيعي بيجي واحد، ممكن يقول لك الآن
بس أنا مشيت من الشركة، إيه بس أنت غيابات
إيه طبعًا، احنا نتكلم عنه في الوضع الطبيعي
هو عقده مستمر حتى لو الشركة ما لقيت مشاريع
هذه مسؤولية الشركة
بس بضيف برضه على الموضوع أيش الفوائد
مكافأة نهاية الخدمة تحسب في التكلفة
الشركات الثانية ما فيها مكافأة نهاية الخدمة؟
إذا المعدل دوران الموظفين في قطاع التجزئة
وهو أقرب قطاع لقطاع الخدمات الأمنية
لسه ممكن أن تكون النسبة أكبر
أكثر من 50% دوران موظفين
المستثمر راح يكون عنده رغبة أنه ما يحسبها
أنها ما تحصل؛ عشان يخفّض أسعاره
فأنت عندك مكافأة نهاية الخدمة، عندك الإجازات
شلون موضوع الإجازات؟ غيركم ما عنده إجازات؟
ممكن في بعض الأحيان يكون أنت عملك بالشكل هذا
طبعًا أنا ما أعمم، أنا أرجع وأقول لك إياها مرة ثانية
هذا التعميم غير وارد
لكن أنت تسألني ليش صار فيه 300 ألف في المنصة؟
نحن نتكلم عن ممارسات عامة في السوق أو شائعة
أيوة، وما لها علاقة بالقطاع الأمني
هذه الممارسات برضه في أماكن ثانية
أنتوا الإجازات عندكم كم؟ ثلاثين يوم؟
الإجازات اثنين وعشرين يوم إجازة للموظف
أضف إلى ذلك التأمينات الاجتماعية على راتبه وليس كحد أدنى
أضف إلى ذلك التأمين الصحي
من يستفيد من الشركة اليوم أكثر من 13 ألف موظف
طبعًا بتقول لي أنت 9000 كيف صارت؟
لأن هذول عوائلهم، التأمين الصحي بشكل معين
أي فئة التأمين؟
أفضل فئة، طبعًا ليش أقول لك أفضل فئة
لأن تعريف أفضل فئة هذا مختلف
طبعًا ممكن أعطيك «إيه» ولا فيها شبكة جيدة
لأن برضه جزء من العمل المؤسسي
أن أنت تعمل على مستوى المملكة
فممكن يكون عندك مستشفيات في الرياض
بس ما عندك مستشفيات في جيزان
صح
فهذه احنا أخذنا جزء كبير في توعية الموظفين
ترى يا جماعة هو مو الحرف اللي ينحط
هو كلنا احنا فائدتنا من التأمين الصحي كيف
فأنتم تضمنون أن أعلى فئة من التأمين لهذا الموظف
ولما قلنا 50% بكل ما يتبادر من عدم رضا
دوران موظفين عندنا أقل من 10%
في القطاع 50% ومعدل دوران موظفين
طبعًا أتكلم أنا الميدانيين
6% بس، وللا كم؟
أنا قلت أقل من 10% كيف قلت 6%؟
لأن هنا واحد مرسل لي يقول ترى الدوام الوظيفي عندهم 60%
لا، لا
فقلت يمكن أنه مزود صفر وللا
لا، هو أقل من 10%
أقل من 10%؟
في الميدانيين أقل من 10%
في الإدراة الرئيسي أنا ممكن أقول لك النسبة مرتفعة
أكثر من الأعمال الميدانية
طبعًا لأن احنا مطالبين في الإدارة الرئيسية
بإرضاء زملاءنا في الميدان
هذه كلها تخص عملية ومزايا الموظفين
أو التحسين اللي سويتوه في ظروف العمل
فيه مجموعة أسئلة للأشخاص اللي يعملون في «سيف»
بس بنخليه لأخر الحلقة
لأن الآن بكمل معاكم التحول اللي أنتم تسوونه
فهذا التحول اللي حصل فيه مزايا وحوافز وآلية استقطاب للموظفين
أيش فيه تحول آخر صار من خلال الخدمات
أو البرامج اللي أنتم تقدمونها لعملائكم والسوق؟
ممتاز، هذا على مستوى الموظف
على مستوى زملاءنا مقدمين الخدمة
تم عرض عليهم نظام اشتراك في مراكز التحكم
بدل أن ينشئ مراكز التحكم يكون مطلوب منهم...
زملائكم تقصد الشركات الأخرى اللي في السوق
مزودينهم
أيش قدمتوا لهم؟
احنا الآن عندنا جزء من الخدمة اللي نقدمها
اللي يسمونها نظام الإنذار المراقب
يعني أنت ما يحتاج تحط موظف أمن
أنت تربط الأنظمة اللي عندك بمركز التحكم
بمجرد ما يصيح أو بمجرد ما يضرب الإنذار عندك
تباشر الدورية الأمنية عملها وتفحص الموقع
وهذه بمقابل مادي؟
هذه بمقابل ويعتبر مقابل اشتراك
أنت لك أن تتخيل بناء مركز تحكم باشتراك حسب الحاجة
حاجة حلوة، فأنا كشركة حراسات أمنية في القطاع
ماني مضطر أبني مركز تحكم، أقدر أشترك في مركزكم
واشتراك بمبلغ مقطوع أو شهري
ومبلغ إضافي على الحالات اللي تحدث
خليني أقول لك كيف تغير النموذج
كان من الشركات للشركات الآن
هذا خلق لنا من الشركات للأفراد
أصبح العميل ما يذهب لشركة أمنية
يقول لك أنا أبغى الخدمة منك بشكل مباشر
نسأل عمر في المستقبل
بكرة أنا عندي بيت، أقدر أحصل على الخدمة هذه؟
نعم أنزل لك الكاميرات، وإذا صار عندي إنذار
أتعامل مع الإنذار، وأقول لك ترى طلع إنذار كاذب
أيش السبب؟ انتشار
فاليوم هذه الخدمة صارت حتى للأفراد
موجودة للأفراد وانطلبت
وهذه إضافة أنتم سويتوها في القطاع بموضوع الربط معاهم
نعم
وأيش فيه كذلك؟
عندك برضه تدريب تكلمنا عليه بشكل كافي في البداية
اليوم أنتم تدربون حتى للغير
إيه، بس هو هنا وين الموضوع اللي نبغى نذكره
في ذلك اللقاء، المعالي تفضل وقال احنا عرضنا على تدريب الشركات
طبعًا أنا تفاجأت بمعرفة التفاصيل هذه عن الشركة
الله يعطيه القوة والعافية
بعد كذا احنا، بعد ما تكلمنا عن الموضوع هذا
حصل قصة عززت من موضوع التدريب
أنا بحكم أن عندي أبناء، فابني الصغير دائمًا أروح معه المناسبات
لأن ما يقدر يروحها لوحده
ففي أحد المناسبات، دخلت المناسبة لقيت موظفين «سيف»
وأنا أعرف أن المناسبة هذه ما احنا مغطينها
فأنا سلمت على الشباب، وقلت له احنا مغطين المنطقة هذه؟ قال لها لا
بس شوف الوعي اللي حصل، أول وعي حصل قال لك
ترى «سيف» احنا محافظين عن العلامة التجارية حقته
احنا جايين هنا بصفة أخرى، بصفة شخصية ما لها علاقة بالشركة
فأنت شفت موظفين حراس أمن «سيف»
موجودين في فعالية ما لكم علاقة فيها
أيوة
جايين بصفتهم الشخصية
بصفتهم الشخصية
وبزي ماهو زي «سيف»
صحيح، فهذه خدمة ثانية قدمناها للقطاع
أصبح القطاع يستغل العقود الجديدة
من وزارة الشؤون الاجتماعية والموارد البشرية
فيه العقود المرنة، عقود الدوام الجزئي؛ فأصبح الموظفين حقنا
دخل إضافي لهم
هو دخل إضافي لهم، وبرضه أصبح شركاءنا في القطاع
إذا كان هو موظف «سيف» يقدر ياخذه
لأنه فحص السموم وصحيفة السوابق وعنده خبرات
مضمون أنه غطى كل المتطلبات
صرنا مثل المنصة مع عدم موجود منصة
مع أن المنصة التقنية موجودة
فكان الحوار بعد ذلك مع الزملاء نفسهم
أنا أتكلم مع الزملاء في الميدان، وهم عزيزين جدًّا على قلبي
لأن هم الواجهة الحقيقية للشركة
فجات من بعدها الفكرة، قالوا أبو سلمان، ترى زملاءنا يبون يتدربون
حتى اللي هم من غير وظيفة في الشركة
فأخذت الفكرة وكان فيه الاجتماع الأسبوعي
وتكلمنا مع الزملاء، يا شباب احنا نبغي ناخذ قرار
اللي بغي يتدرب في المجتمع؛ يستطيع أن يتدرب فيه «سيف»
فكان هناك مقاومة شرسة من الزملاء، هو من ردة الفعل
قالوا يا أبو سلمان، إذا تدربوا الزملاء في القطاع عندنا
ما نبغي يصير عندهم انطباع أن احنا ملزمين بالتوظيف
قلت احنا الرسالة اللي وصلتنا
أن هناك ناس في القطاع يحتاجون يتدربون
من واجبنا واحد أسبابنا أن احنا موجودين في القطاع هذا
أن نلبي رغباتهم
والعاملين في القطاع جزء منه، والحل بسيط
يوقع المتدرب قبل لا يأخذ الدورة
اقرار بأن أنا أعلم أنه هذه غير منتهية بالتوظيف
وتمت العملية
والحمد لله، الأرقام الآن تدلل على أن القطاع واعد، وعنده رغبة...
كم عدد اللي تدربوا ومستوياتهم؟
4000 هذول من خارج الشركة
4000 من خارج الشركة؟
تدربوا بمقابل، دفعوا من جيبهم فلوس
عشان يحصلوا على الدورة التجريبية
يوجد عنده رغبة، هناك من يعمل في القطاع يود أن يتعلم
أضف إلى ذلك، أن احنا ما كان الهدف مادي
لأن لما ياخذ الموظف الشهادة هذه المعتمدة عالميًّا
يستطيع أن يعمل في «سيف» وغير «سيف»
في السعودية وخارج السعودية
يستطيع رجل الأمن أو موظفة الأمن
على الأقل تضع شيء في السيرة الذاتية
فهذه إضافة ثانية صارت في القطاع
أيش فيه إضافة ثالثة ممكن نحكي عنها
وقد يكون شيء مرتبط بالحلول التقنية
لأن ذكرت لما شفت القطاع أو كثير من الشركات القطاع بدائية
وتعتمد على أن حط رجل الأمن وبس
ما فيه أي نوع من تفعيل التقنية أو الحلول التقنية
خلينا نبدأ من رحلة العميل
كإدارة الاستشارات الأمنية بدأت تعمل مع العملاء
حتى على عملية الطرح
هل أنت تحتاج عقد خدمة؟ وللا عقد كمي؟
أيش الأفضل؟ عقد الخدمة أفضل
لأن إتفاقية مستوى الخدمة مع مؤشرات الأداء الرئيسية
أنت مسؤول الخدمة ما لك علاقة بالموظفين
أيش الفائدة من إمدادك؟
لما نعطيك موظفين أنت راح تديرهم
هل عندك الكيان هذا؟ هل تبغى تعيش الكيان هذا؟
الموضوع الآخر، يمكن أن أدير لك الموضوع هذا
فكوّنت له خيارات كثيرة
نجي إلى موضوع مراكز التحكم
مراكز التحكم وفرت حلول جدًّا كثيرة
والجميل أن احنا نفكر بمفاهيم وليس بمنتجات
فمفهوم العمل عن بُعد، اللي هو المفهوم الرصدي عن بُعد
مفهوم التقييم عن بُعد، وعندك مفهوم الخدمات الميدانية
وعندك مفهوم الخدمات الذاتية
وعندك مفهوم الخدمات المؤتمتة
وعندك مفهوم الخدمات الغير مأهولة
هذه كلها الآن موجودة
عندك التلوث البصري الآن يوجد دورية مع أحد شركائنا
متقدمين في تقنية الكشف
دوريات أمنية الآن ترصد التلوث البصري
من خلال دوريات «سيف»
فهذه التقنية منفذة
بعد النجاح اللي حققناه في الموضوع هذا
أصبحت عملية التعيين في المشاريع هذه جدًّا عالية
الموضوع الثاني، نعمل كثير في المناطق النائية
الأسطول هذا كله؛ أكبر أسطول في الشركات الأمنية تبع «سيف»
يتابع من قبل مركز التحكم
خطوة إضافية ثانية، الموظف إذا استخدم جواله وهو يقود السيارة
أو حصل له تعب أو نعس؛ يجي عندنا الآن في مركز التحكم
فيه خدمات جدًّا كثيرة
تمييز الوجوه، عندنا المبنى مسوينه مركز تقديم الخبرات
فلو يدخل أحد ماهو من المنشأة والتقطه الكاميرا
راح يطلع في مركز التحكم
طبعًا احنا بالنسبة لنا مركز تقديم للخبرات
فأي عميل يجي؛ نقدم له الخدمات
القائمة ما يشوفها في نشرة، يشوفها أمامه
يعيشها في داخل المبنى
مركز التحكم يعتبر أكبر مركز تحكم في المنطقة لشركة أمنية خاصة
بدأنا نقدم خدمات مكافحة الحرائق والأمن
طيب الآن لما نجي نعزز خدمة التقنية هذه
الإشكالية لما يجي صاحب التقنية
يطلب التقنية هو يطلب عدد، عطني ستين أو سبعين كاميرا
أربعين أو سبعين فرد
لكن احنا اللي قاعدين نقول له لا، اطلب استشارة
لأن أنت ممكن تحتاج ست كاميرات
لما توضع في مكان بشكل مناسب، هذا واحد
رقم اثنين، أنت ممكن توضع الكاميرات هذه تعد
وتسوي تحكم بالوصول، وتسوي كشف عن الحرائق
بنفس الكاميرا وتحط فيها ذكاء اصطناعي
وممكن أن أنت تحط عد
وممكن أنت كجهة تعمل في القطاع العقاري
تعرف وين المتر المفروض يرتفع بناءً على الحشود اللي موجودة عندك
هذه كل الخدمات موجودة
هذه لو بلخصها في خدمة جديدة
ما كانت تقدم من أغلب شركات الحراسات الأمنية
اللي هي تقديم الاستشارات ما قبل المناقصة
قبلما العميل أو صاحب المنشأة يقول
أنا أبي مئة فرد وأبي ستين كاميرا
أنتوا تجلسون معاه، وتقدمون له المشورة في العدد الأنسب
وكل الخدمات اللي يحتاجها
فهذه بحد ذاتها خدمة اليوم تقدمونها
بعدها تطرح المناقصة وتصيرون تقدمون مثلكم مثل غيركم
صحيح، هذا جزء جدًّا رائع تفضلت فيه عمر
ليس بالضرورة أني وفرت الاستشارة راح أحصل عقد
يحصل عقد في شركة ثانية
بس أنتم طبعًا مفصلينها بحيث أن ما حد يقدر عليه إلا أنتم
ما أعتقد ذلك
لأن لما أنا أفصله بالشكل هذا؛ العميل له دور
بيكون ذكي بالذات لما استخدم شيء معقد
أنا أتكلم لك لو أنت طالب مراقبين أمن؛ ما فيه شيء معقد
تبغاهم مدربين وللا ما تبغاهم مدربين
ترى فيها فرق في التكلفة
حتى لو ما يبغاهم مدربين
راح يضع صاحب الشركة مدربين ويجي يدرب عندي
بدل ما ينشئ كيان عنده للتدريب
أو ما يجي يدرب، يجي يتدرب عند «سيف»
الكيان هذا، إن شاء الله، باقي إلى فترة طويلة
لأن طموحنا ماهو فقط بفترة بسيطة
مركز التحكم، هذا مثال على تقنيات جديدة أنتم قدمتوها
تكلمنا عن السيارات أو الدوريات اللي ترصد التشوه البصري
أيش فيه تقنيات أخرى اليوم قاعدة تستخدم
ماهي موجودة عادةً في القطاع؟
كاميرا الجسم، الآن عندنا الكاميرات اللي توضع لرجل الأمن
كثير من الأحيان تصبح إشكاليات
لما يكون هناك تواصل بشري وشخصي ما بين اثنين
الآن من زملاءنا في الميدان يستطيع أن يركب كاميرا
وينزل للتعامل مع أي أحد، هذا يحفظه هو من أي خطر
ويحفظ برضه هيبة رجل الأمن
لأن ترى كل شيء ما تستطيع أن تدّعي أن حصل واحد، اثنين، ثلاثة
أضف إلى ذلك أن ممكن أن يتخاطب معاه مركز التحكم
من خلال الكاميرا
الدوريات الأمنية اللي موجودة من خلال الإضاءات
اللي يسمونها الإضاءات دورية
يوجد فيها ما يقارب اثنا عشر كاميرا ترصد
أيش تبي ترصد؟ تبي ترصد التشوه البصري
تبي ترصد موقف مخالف، تبي ترصد زحام
تبي ترصد حالة طارئة كيف ممكن تتعامل فيها
ممكن الجهات المختصة ما يكون عندها رجل أمن في مكان معين
بس بحكم انتشارنا، يتم التواصل مع مركز التحكم
هل يوجد لديكم رجل أمن؟
احنا نحتاج الين ما نوصل للمعلومات الفلانية أو الموضوع الفلاني
هذا كله موجود
الهدف هو إيجاد كيان جاهز متى ما دعت الحاجة
سواءً من الجهات المختصة أو مزودي الخدمة أو العميل أو الموظفين
ولو بلخص كل هذه القدرات
احنا قلنا فيه 8500 شخص
نعم
كم مركبة؟
900 مركبة
كم مركز تحكم؟
مركز تحكم واحد، ليش؟
مراكز التحكم جودتها ليست بزيادة عددها
هي ميزتها في أنها أصلًا تعمل عن بُعد
لو تقول لنا أيش الهدف؟
أنا أقول لك الهدف عندنا أن ما يكون فيه تعدد لمراكز التحكم، ليش؟
لأن حتى المبنى لما اخترناه؛ اخترناه بشكل كروي
على أساس نطبق فيه «حلقات البصل»
اللي هو العمليات الحرجة اليوم هنا
مع التوسع تصبح عملية أقل حرجة
فالهدف اسمه مركز
كم مشروع عندكم اليوم أو كم عميل؟
أكثر من أربعين عميل
كلهم طبعًا صندوق الاستثمارات العامة، شركات ربعكم
توقعون معاهم وفلوسكم تدور على بعضكم
والله شوف أنا أتمنى، ولكن طرح جدًّا رائع
أنا جدًّا سعيد أنك طرحت النقطة هذه
مشاريع الصندوق ما تمثل النسبة الأكبر، هذا رقم واحد
من اثنين وأربعين مشروع كم شركات الصندوق؟
أعتقد 40%
مو أربع شركات
بس أنت لما تتكلم، في بعض الكيانات حجمها جدًّا صغير
تزيد معك في العدد هذا، لكن لما تجي تتكلم عن أرقام ربحية
ماهي عدد كبير
فقط 40% شركات الصندوق؟
نعم
وشركات الصندوق اللي ما استعانوا فيكم
ليش زعلانين منكم؟ أيش كانت ملاحظاتهم؟
شوف احنا نتكلم بشكل عام
الحوكمة عالية جدًّا في مشاريع الصندوق
والحاصل الآن أن من يقرر في هذه المواضيع
هي إدارة العقود والمشتريات في هذه الكيانات
خلني أضرب لك مثال، بما أنك بديت أول الحلقة
بأنكم تبغون تكونون شركاء في قطاع الترفيه
ومع اللي صاير في البلد وكواجهة البلد مع السياح، وإلى آخره
شركة شقيقة لكم، واللي هي شركة «صلة»
هي المسؤولة عن منطقة «البوليفارد»
وعن مشاريع الترفيه اللي في كذا موقع
ما أذكر أني شفت موظفين «سيف» في «البوليفارد» في الرياض
صحيح
فمو موقعين معاكم هم؟
ليش؟
الخدمة موجودة، رأوا من منظورهم في أعمالهم
أن ما تستدعي ممكن هذا المستوى من الخدمة
رأوا أن ممكن يكون هناك تحزيم للخدمات بشكل مختلف
ولكن التعاون موجود
كان فيه دعم سابق في أكثر من مشروع
والدعم كان ملاحظ فيه أن بعض المناطق
حساسيتها عالية في أن تأتي «سيف» في المناطق الحرجة هذه
فيه تعاون سابق، ولكن كل كيان من الكيانات اللي موجودة
يحق له أن يختار الخدمة بما يتناسب مع احتياجاته
وممكن نظروا في الاعتبار من خلال مثلًا
إدارة تقنية المعلومات أو المدينة الذكية
لأن مشكلة الخدمة هذه أصبحت مدمجة
أصبحت في كل منظومة
أنت تتكلم عن المدينة الذكية ترى فيه حماية
تتكلم عن تقنية المعلومات، يسمونها تقنيات الميدانية والتشغيلية
فكل كيان يستطيع أن يعمل
طالما نسولف عن المشاريع
كل الكلام السابق كلام نظري جميل
أتوقع بنقدر نبسطه للناس ونربط الناس
في الأثر اللي أضافته «سيف» للسوق
من خلال أمثلة  لمشاريعكم
لو تعطينا أمثلة من العقود أو المشاريع أو المواقع
اللي أنتم ماسكينها، أيش فرق أنكم موجودين
ومو بأي شركة ثانية في السوق؟
والله فيه سلسلة فنادق مشهورة جدًّا
حتى تقديم الخدمة من الخارج
فكانت تجربة الفندق، يقول لك أنا أعمل مع «سيف» بأي تكلفة
فكان السؤال ليش؟
قال في بعض الأحيان، بعض الزوار أصبحوا يعرفون
بعض رجال الأمن وبعض موظفات الأمن
اللي عندكم من جودة التعامل
الاستقبال، الاعتذار للتعطيل
لما يجي يدخل للمنشأة، معليش هذا فحص أمني لازم احنا نسويه
أحد الزملاء كلمني سابقًا
قال لي والله يا أبوسلمان أنا عندي ملاحظة
طبعًا الجميل بعض الأحيان تجيك ملاحظات إيجابية
فقلت له عسى ما شر، وهو لأنه كان شخص تنفيذي في أحد الكيانات
فقال يا أخي، رجل الأمن اللي عندكم متعبني
فقلت غريبة، فيه مشرف عام، كان ممكن أن يتبلغ
قال لا، الموضوع مختلف
قلت له أيش؟ قال أنا أطلع من المكتب وأرجع من المكتب كثير
قلت طيب! من حقك
قال لي بس رجل الأمن اللي موجود عندنا في المنطقة اللي نمر
دائمًا إذا مريت أو مر أي أحد يوقّف
فصرت أنا أتحرّج أني أطلع، وقلت له أكثر من مرة ما في داعي
يوقف يعني يقف من باب أنه احترام؟
أول شيء احنا في عاداتنا وثقافتنا، لما أحد يدخل عليك كضيف تقف
صح
أنت لما يجي يسلم عليك أحد؛ تاخذه بالتوازي كنظير
أنت لما تبغى تكون مرحِّب
أنت لما تبغى تكون مستعد لأي خطر؛ تقف
فلما فهموا الزملاء في الميدان فلسفة الوقوف
اكتسبوا القوة من سلوكهم
وقبل احنا نبدأ، قلنا لهم ترى الزي الرسمي يعتبر أول قوة لك
لأن لو جاء واحد بثوبه وتصرف تصرف معين
يقولون لك أنت بأي صفة
بالزي الرسمي؛ راح يقول له أنا رجل أمن، أنا مسؤول، وهذا واضح
ولكن هناك جانب آخر، طول ما أنت لابس الزي هذا
يجب أن تمثله بشكل جيد
غير مثال موضوع الفنادق، أيش فيه غيرها أمثله؟
عندك الآن مع المشاريع السياحية اللي حاصلة
وهذا كان في السابق لا تستطيع الجهة تقدمه
حصل فيه طلب، قالوا أنتوا تقدمون الخدمة لنا
مبسوطين احنا من الخدمة
ولكن نحن نرغب في خدمة مصممة لنا بشكل خاص
تستطيعون تساعدون؟
كان عندك مشروع ترفيهي على البحر
يحتاج أن رجل الأمن يكون مدرب
على أن يعرف يتعامل مع الحوادث البحرية
ويعرف يتعامل مع المناسبة لأنها كانت مثل الدوري
ويعرف يتعامل مع الشخصيات المهمة في المناطق الساحلية
تقدرون تساعدونا؟
نساعدهم
أيش تبون؟ قالوا والله احنا ما ندري، قلت طيب
هذه استشارة، تفضلوا هذه المعايير العالمية تقول لك بالشكل هذا
أنت تعمل على الأماكن الساحلية بالشكل هذا وبالشكل هذا
وتم تصميم الحقيبة التدريبية
بعد كذا انتقلنا، راحوا راجعوها قالوا لنا
نبغى نعدل هنا ونضبط هنا، ورجعت
نبغى نطبقها، كيف نطبقها؟ ما في معاهد
وكان جزء من الدورة التدريب على السباحة
وجزء من الدورة التدريب على الدفاع عن النفس
وتم توفير هذه كلها للعميل (Tailor Made Service) «خدمة مصممة خصيصًا»
تتكلم على مناطق ثقافية لا يوجد حولها أحد
احنا نغطي المناطق هذه من خلال...
أنا توني تعرفت على المملكة من خلال انتشار زملائي في الميدان
وصراحة يعتبر تحدي الحاصل
دخلت موقعكم ما شفت قائمة عملاؤكم، ليش مخبينهم؟
لا مو مخبينهم، احنا جزء من العمل
أن يكون عرض عملاءنا خلال اجتماعات رسمية كعمل
بعض الأحيان يجب أن...
هو بيضر بالعملاء؟ لأن خلاص زيكم معروف
بشوفه، أنا موجود
حقيقةً أكون صادق معك أنا صريح
هل يوجد سبب يا بشاير؟
لا..
بس في الموقع الرسمي ما في عملاؤكم
طيب تقدر تقول عن عملاءك؟ تقدر تقول من هم عملاءك؟
ممكن نعطي شريحة من العملاء
عطنا أمثلة
نتكلم عن أن عملاءنا وزارة الثقافة
أنا أحاول أن أتجنب من مغزى السؤال، لكن خلنا نكون صريحين
إيه
«العُلا»
عندنا وزارة الثقافة، عندنا «العُلا» عندنا المركز المالي، عندنا «نيوم»
أنا جيتك على أساس بترد علي بعد شوية
عندنا «تحكم» عندنا «أرامكو» عندنا «البنك المركزي»
عندنا «إس تي سي» عندنا «النقل المؤتمن للبنوك»
بعض البنوك برضه موجودة عندنا
خليني أعطيك بس كذا بشكل سريع المشاريع الأيقونية
في بدايات الشركة كان مجموعة العشرين كمناسبة
وكان في منطقة نائية، ما كان عندنا موارد كافية
لطلب الموارد بشكل سريع
الفريق التنفيذي هو اللي وصّل الموارد في منطقة
هذا في الغربية
أيوة، في منطقة نائية تبعد أكثر من...
أنت الظاهر كنت واحد من اللي ساقوا، صح؟
لأن جاتني رسالة، قالت لي الرئيس خذ السيارة ووصّل
أنا قلت الفريق التنفيذي، شوف والله أنا ما أحب أقول أنه أنا
هو صحيح، هو هذا اللي حصل
أن أنا قلت أيش يحتاجون الشباب هناك؟
هي قصة مؤثرة حتى، قلت الشباب أيش يحتاجون؟ أيش اللي متعطل؟
فقالوا والله السيارات، وأنا شفت أن الموضوع أخذ من وقته
قلت أنا بروح الآن للموقع
والله ما كان عندي الخطة بالشكل هذا
ولكن وصلت للموقع والسيارات جاهزة
كم بياخذ وقت؟ قالوا بندور أحد يوصل أو شيء مثل كذا
قلت طيب خلني أجرب السيارة، طبعًا هو خلني أجرب السيارة
كان معي واحد من الزملاء الله يذكره بالخير، الأخ «محمد عسيري»
فمشينا، قال لي وين رايح؟ قلت أبد بنمشي بنروح بس أشوف السيارة
استهلاك البنزين وكذا، شوي عدينا القصيم
قال أبو سلمان وين رايحين؟
قلت والله الدوريات توصل، اليوم توصل، توصل
وصلنا للموقع وانصدم مدير الحلول الأمنية
وهو كان موجود في الموقع، وهو اللي كان منزعج من عدم الوصول
كان عندكم مشكلة أنكم توصل السيارات للموقع
الأسطول اللي في شمال السعودية
أيوة. فانصدم هو، قال لي أنت جاي بنفسك!
قلت والله اليوم توصل
قال لي روح ارتاح وبعدين...
قلت أنا ما راح اترك الموقع لين ما أشوفها توصل
وبعدين بكرة راح يبدأ الحدث
فراح واختصر الطريق
من ضمن المشاريع اللي شفناها برضه
وهذه ما فهمتها صراحة، فيديو لكم
أو لبعض منسوبيكم في قطر كأس العالم
أيش علاقتكم في كأس العالم؟
نرجع للمشاريع الأيقونية، فقلنا احنا مجموعة العشرين
وبعدين نتكلم على الـ«إس تي سي» شركة الاتصالات السعودية
هذا المشروع في 2021
طبعًا أن يكون معك شريك مثل الاتصالات السعودية
ممن يهتم بموظفي القطاع كان إضافة جدًّا كبيرة
وساعدتنا كثير على النجاح
السنة اللي بعدها 2022 كانت كأس العالم في قطر
وكأس العالم في قطر كان له قصة
كنا في الطيارة راجعين من جدة ومجهدين
وأنا قلت للشباب جهزوا أنفسكم لقطر
والله ما كان فيه أي...
فهم الشباب بحكم أني أعلى منصب
شفت في عيونهم كذا، إن شاء الله، أبشر
تسليك
إن شاء الله خير
قبل البطولة بثلاثة اسابيع
إخواننا في قطر فتحوا المجال للتعاون والمساهمة
في إنجاح دورة ناجحة نعتبرها
قبل أن تحصل الجهود اللي شفتها جدًّا كبيرة
واحنا والله كان للشرف أن احنا ساهمنا في البطولة
خلال أقل من ثلاثة أسابيع
شلون؟ هي طُرحت كمناقصات أو كمشاريع
وللا هي فزعة بدون مقابل وللا أيش؟
لا، هو طُرح كمشروع، كان هناك حاجة لعدد معين في مواقع معينة
وتم تصنيف المواقع
كل قطاع من الدول اللي جاية تقوم بأداء عمل
ولكن القطاع الخاص كانت «سيف» تلعب فيه دور كبير
وطُلب أكثر من ألف موظف
طبعًا الطلب ألف موظف لازم تسوي لك خلطة
بحيث أن يكون فيه خبراء برضه في العملية
طلبوا الخبراء، أعطيناهم الخبراء بالموضوع
شافوا الموضوع هذا وأُتيحت لنا الفرصة
تم نقل الموظفين بطائرات خاصة على المنافذ
نقلتوا ألف موظف
أغلب الموظفين، لأن كان هنالك تحدي في الوقت
تم نقلهم بطائرات خاصة إلى المنفذ
تم توجه الموظفين إلى المواقع
ساهمت لجنة المشاريع والإرث كثير في تسهيل الأمور
بحكم أن الفترة كانت قصيرة
تم توفير الخدمة للمواقع المستهدفة
الجميل في الموضوع، كان فيه قصص
تكلمنا مثلًا عن الخدمات اللوجستية، الوجبات الغذائية
لما كنا نطلب للموظفين، كانوا نفس اللي يزودوننا بالوجبات ما يصدق
يقول في تاريخ المطعم كله ما انطلبت الكمية ذي
هذه تجي تستلمها، هذا جزء من الموضوع
احنا برضه في الخدمات اللوجستية، بعض الزملاء اشتغلوا في مواقع
الإخوان القطريين رفضوا ان احنا نوفر الوجبات الغذائية
هذولا احنا نبغي نساهم
كرم الضيافة
كان فيه تلاحم جدًّا كبير في الموضوع
إخواننا بعدين في نهاية الحفل اللي أديناه للزملاء
لشكرهم بعد انتهاء التعاقد
قالوا احنا كنا جدًّا سعيدين، بحكم أن احنا من نسيج واحد
لما عملتوا في المنطقة اعطيتوا عبق وبُعد للثقافة الخليجية
طبعًا تم التعاون في أكثر من حادثة
لإدارة الحشود، لدعم الجهات المختصة
جزء من التطوير اللي حصل في «سيف»
مظهر رجل الأمن، أحد الشركات اللي مارست عملها بالزي شركة «سيف»
هذا لما أقولك تم بناء هوية، إعادة تجديد
تقصد أنهم مارسوا عملهم في قطر
بالزي حق شركة «سيف» ما لبسوا زي آخر
لا، لاقي استحسانهم، لأن أنت لما تؤدي عمل بشكل جيد؛ هذه النتيجة
وكان هذه اتفاقية تجارية بحتة
تجارية بحتة
بمقابل مادي مجدي
حقيقةً يكفي الإضافة لهوية «سيف»
أنها كانت من ضمن الجهات المشاركة
هل هذا حمسكم تشتغلون في دول أخرى؟
احنا نعمل الآن في البحرين، وتم فتح مكتب في الإمارات
وعما قريب، إن شاء الله، بنكون في قارة مختلفة
في قارة مختلفة، إفريقيا؟
شمال إفريقيا ممكن، إن شاء الله
ما شاء الله، ما دامنا نتكلم عن المستقبل
شفنا وحدة من آخر أخباركم
استحوذتوا على وحدة إدارة الأموال في شركة «أبانا»
هذا أول استحواذ لكم صح؟
أول استحواذ
أيش قصته؟ ليش هذا الاستحواذ على عكس أنشطتكم الأخرى
اللي كانت تنشأ من داخل الشركة وتؤسس من الصفر؟
طبعًا احنا قلنا 2021 «إس تي سي» 2022 بطولة قطر
2023 استحواذنا على قطاع أعمال لخدمات النقل المؤتمن في «أبانا»
فتم الاستحواذ على القطاع هذا
والقطاع هذا مكّننا، الحمد لله، من اختراق بنسبة 30% من الحصة السوقية
المستهدف هو تغيير نموذج العمل
فاحنا كان الهدف أن نحصل على ما يمكننا لتغيير نموذج العمل
تغيير نموذج العمل هو بعمل تكامل متقدم وتكامل متأخر
والمقصود فيه العودة للتكامل
أنا أبغى أقدم خدمات إضافية غير خدمة النقل المؤتمن
كلام معقد أبو سلمان، ما فهمت، بسّط لي إياه
أنت استحوذت عليهم ليش؟
لأنك أنت تبغى تقدم الخدمة هذه؟
أبغى أغيّر نموذج العمل
شلون؟ أيش نموذج العمل الحالي وأيش نموذج العمل اللي تبغاه؟
نموذج العمل الحالي مبني على نقل أموال
فيه توجه من قِبل المشرّع أن يكون هنالك مركز نقد متعدد الخدمة
يخدم أكثر من بنك، هو حاليًّا يقدم خدمة لأحد
فلا بد يكون فيه ذراع تشغيلي
في القطاع الخاص يشتغل على الموضوع هذا
طبعًا الاستثمار في الفكرة هذه راح يولّد لك برضه
عملية اتفاقية الخدمة
بدل من أن البنك ممكن يحصل على المكينة
ممكن أن أنت تساهم
طبعًا هو هنا ندخل في الطريقة المستقبلية
اللي احنا نفضّل أن يراها العاملين في القطاع أكثر من أن نتحدث عنه
وفيه كان كلام على أن كان فيه محاولات من داخل «سيف»
لهذا القطاع ولم تنجح، ما قدر أن يخترق ويكسب عملاء
فلجأ إلى الاستحواذ
كان فيه محاولات غير ناجحة لقطاع إدارة الأموال أو نقل الأموال؟
بالعكس، كان هناك دعم كبير
الدعم موجود، بس هل أخذتوا عقود؟
لا، كان فيه دعم من المشرّع، لأن كان فيه تأني
إذا بقدم نفس الخدمة؛ أعتقد يجب إعادة النظر في الموضوع
لكن التأني اللي حاصل، لأن احنا رحنا وشوفنا السوق
درسنا كيف نبي ندخل في السوق
أيش أفضل طريقة للدخول في السوق
طبعًا أنا لو دخلت بشكل ابتدائي مثل ما تفضلت أنت
الزيادة هذه الـ 30% ترى في النهاية راح تحصل
اللهم أن أنا كان عندي نمو، ولكن دون توجّه
لكن أنا أخذت الـ 30% عن طريق الاستحواذ
والآن بإذن الكريم راح أكون جاهز لعملية تغيير النموذج
والآثار، إن شاء الله، ممكن تشوفونها قريبًا
نحن اللي قاعدين نقول نموذج العمل، بإذن الكريم
سنحاول في القطاع الخاص تعزيز دوره من خلال تغيير نموذج العمل
في قطاع حماية كبار الشخصيات
يبدو أنه موجود كمسمى بس مو مفعل
هذا أكبر دليل أنه مفعل
شلون؟ آه أنت تبغانا كذا سريين
طبعًا، هي حماية شخصيات، أروح أنا أعرض أسماء الناس
اللي تم توفير الحماية لهم!
لا بالعكس، الخدمة تقدم ويوجد سيارات مصفحة، والخدمة قائمة
كم كبير شخصية تحرسونه؟
هي طبعًا خدمات حماية الشخصيات نوعين
فيه نوع دائم، وفيه نوع مؤقت
فالغالب تكون مؤقتة
مؤقتة؛ مربوطة بوجودة في مكان معين، في لحظة معينة
نعم
وهذا عادةً التعاقد مع الشخص، فهي من الشركة للأفراد
وللا هي من شركة لشركة أو مع جهة تبغى تحرس قياداتها
يعتمد، لأن ما نبغى نعطي طابع شوي له أبعاد أخرى
نتكلم مثلًا شخصية مشهورة
فهو ممكن الشخصية المشهورة هذه يكون عنده شركات تدير
فهذا من شركة لشركة، وممكن يكون تعاقد مباشر
الشخص نفسه يقول أنا
إيه، لأن برضه هو بعض الأحيان ينظر في الموضوع
أن ما أبغى أحد يعرف أنا وين رايح، أنا وين جاي، أيش الخطة
هذه المعلومات ترى جدًّا مهمة تعلمك أيش اللي يحصل
أوه! أنا أتذكر شفت في مركز التحكم لما زرتكم
وروني في الخريطة انتشار حراس لكبار الشخصيات
حتى خارج السعودية في أماكن كثيرة
صحيح
فالخدمة هذه تقدمونها حتى خارج
من خلال شركاء لهم منصات على الخطر اللي حاصل في العالم
يصل التحليل إلى أن ممكن يقول لك
ترى الآن فيه حادث حاليًّا حاصلة في الخط هذا
استخدم خط ثاني
أوه! لهذا المستوى
إيه، نعم
هذا يمكن ملخص جيد لأغلب أعمالكم
والفرق اللي تبغون تحدثونه في القطاع
بس أتوقع نقدر نختم قبلما نروح لأسئلة أصدقاء البرنامج
إلى وين رايحين؟ وأيش أهدافكم في 2030؟
الهدف في 2030 أن احنا نكون ممكّن لخلق مسارات جديدة
والارتقاء بهذا القطاع
هناك تحول حاصل، وإذا ركزنا القطاع في التحول الحاصل
للانتقال بالاعتماد على العنصر البشري إلى التقني إلى الذكاء
أنا ما أبغى أقول ذكاء اصطناعي، أنا أبغى أقول ذكاء أعمال
المعلومات هذه اللي يتم رصدها من خلال الطرفيات الأمنية
راح تكوّن بيانات كبيرة، راح يكون عندك تحليل بيانات
راح يكون عندك قرارات وبيكون عندك حكمة
هذه كلها هي المستقبل
بيكون تعزيز استخدام البنية التحتية الأمنية
اللي تكون مطالبة عن طريق متطلبات يجب أن...
ولكن احنا نبغى نعزز من الاستفادة منه هذه
والمستقبل واعد، ونعتقد أنه لا يوجد خيار
إلا أن نكون معيار للمنطقة والعالم
ببدأ أسئلة من مجموعة من الأصدقاء
أولها أيش تشجع؟
أنتوا رعيتوا «الاتحاد» صح؟
إيه
أنت أيش تشجع؟
أنا ما راح أقول لك أيش أشجع، بس المشكلة أتعاطف مع أبنائي
فإذا لقيتوني في أماكن معين، فأنا رايح عشان عيالي
هذا من الحين، تجهز العصايا قبل الفلقة
بس ليش ما سألتني عن «الاتحاد»؟
هل أنت اخترت «الاتحاد» أولاً كرئيس تنفيذي؟
هل أنت اخترت رعاية «الاتحاد»؟
يا أخي ترى التوفيق بيد رب العالمين
لما أنا يصير العلامة التجارية تبعي
مع ممثل المملكة في بطولة كأس العالم
أعتقد أنه خيار يعتبر رائع
بس اختيار رعاة اللي صارت للشركات هذا كان بتنسيقات خارجية
مو كل شركة اختارت النادي اللي تبغى ترعاه، صح؟
أنتوا ما سويتوا دراسة وقارنتوا الأربعة أندية واخترتوا نادي؟
هو التنسيقات هذه تحصل من خلال مجلس الإدارة
أنت لما تبي تروح تسوي عمل مجلس الإدارة
هذه الميزانيات يجب أن تعتمد
فإذا تعتبر مجلس الإدارة جهة خارجية
فمجلس الإدارة هو اللي ساعدنا في اتخاذ القرار واعتمدوا القرار
هل فيه استحواذات جاية؟
والله العمل قائم، متى ما وجدنا شيء مناسب
والهدف منه بالنسبة لنا كشركة «سيف» ليس فقط استثماري
ولكن يمكّن لتقديم شيء أفضل؛ لن نتردد
كان فيه صراحة مجموعة أسئلة مرة مهمة من الموظفين
أنت ذكرت مجموعة مزايا في موظفين أو في عقود شركة «سيف»
منها الإجازات، بس هنا واحد يشتكي يقول
الضغط علينا كبير، صار لي سنتين مو مسموح لي آخذ إجازة
أنتوا أكيد معطينه عقد وفي العقد حقه إجازة
بس ضاغطينه لدرجة أن هو ما يقدر ياخذ إجازة
فكيف تعلق على هذه؟
هو الضغط اللي حاصل من الإدارة التنفيذية الآن أنهم يطلعوا إجازة
عجيب!
لأن عملية ترحيل الإجازات إشكالية
طبعًا، تكوّن عنده رصيد بعدين
لا، حتى هو لازم يستهلك إجازته قبل نهاية السنة
بس هذا كمّل سنتين بدون ما ياخذ إجازة؟
يجب أن يعاد، بس أقول لك احنا عندنا الآن نتابع إحصائيًّا عملية...
بحكم أن احنا عندنا كثافة موظفين عالية
يمثل مخصص
إذا لم يتم استهلاك الإجازات يمثل مخصص، هذا رقم واحد
رقم اثنين، يجب أن يستمتع بإجازته على حسب النظام
فهذا الموضوع احنا مراقبينه بشكل مباشر
سنتين أنا ما أعتقد، يجب إعادة النظر في الموضوع
وممكن يتواصل مع الزملاء في الإدارة
أيش قناة الشكاوى؟
احنا عندنا ثلاث قنوات
القناة الأولى، من خلال إدارته
القناة الثانية من خلال الخدمة الذاتية للموارد البشرية
يعني ظل شيء ممكن يطلبه
هذا في الموقع؟
إيه
الخدمة الذاتية في الموقع الإلكتروني
هو يرسل له رابط، وخلاص الرابط هذا عنده وهو يدخل منه
ومن خلال التدقيق، هذه قناة ثالثة مالها علاقة بالشركة
وشلون أوصل إلى لجنة المراجعة أو المدقق؟
فيه عندنا حساب، إيميل ورابط وكل حاجة
ومكفولة سرية المعلومات وما يرجع لنا فيها
فأنتم بالنسبة لكم موضوع الإجازات
تشجعون الموظف أن ياخذها
لازم ياخذ إجازة
شكاوى كثيرة أبو سلمان جات على مشروع تحكم
في موضوع بيئة عمل الموظفين، في موضوع ظروفهم
يقول ثمان ساعات مو مسموح لنا نغادر المكان إلا لدورة مياه
أو لتعبئة بنزين
حتى أكل ما نقدر نطلع ناكل
صراحة مو بهذه الصورة الذهنية اللي تو أنت تحكي عنها
والبيئة الجميلة اللي تحكي عنها
كلامك جدًّا صحيح، ولكن فيه أبعاد الحين لازم ننظر فيها
بالنسبة للمشروع، هذا المشروع يعتبر في منطقة بعيدة
على أساس يطلع الموظف ياخذ بريك يحتاج ساعتين إلى ثلاثة
وموضوع بيئة العمل هو ليس موضوع المشروع هذا فقط
هناك عمل من خلال وزارة الموارد البشرية والشؤون الاجتماعية
على بيئة عمل رجال الأمن
فاحنا بالنسبة لنا الآن نأمل على أن يتم خلق المسؤولية، على مين؟
هل هو على مقدم الخدمة؟
أو على صاحب المنشأة؟
لأن صاحب المنشأة لن يسمح لمقدم الخدمة
أن يضع شيء هو ما يبغاه في المنشأة
وصاحب المنشأة لن يتقبل التكاليف الإضافية لبيئة العمل
هذا الموضوع نعمل فيه الآن من خلال الوزارة
بس نبي نبسطها، هذا قاعد ثمان ساعات يبي ياكل
شلون ياكل؟
لا هو منشأة ولا صاحب موقع، أيش الجواب له؟
لا، هو لأن ما في مكان قريب جنبه هو
هو في منطقة نائية
تعرف الموضوع، هو عبارة عن خطوط طويلة للسفر
فهذولي مفترض أنهم يحرسون كاميرات «ساهر» في الطرق السريعة
يا سلام عليك
ويكونون في مواقع ما فيها خدمات
صحيح، ولكن أنت عندك الآن حتى في النظام
هو اللي يحصل تجي دورية بديلة للموضوعين اللي تفضلت فيه
بس ليش مو للأكل؟
لأن الأكل تستطيع أن تأخذه معاك، وهم يستاهلون
ولكن طبيعة المشروع شوية فيها تحدي
أضف إلى ذلك أننا جزء كبير من الموضوع
حاولنا أن نوظف من أهل المنطقة
يكون قريب
أيوة. حتى لما ينتهي العمل حقه؛ يكون متواجد حول المنطقة هذه
هم يستاهلون، ولكن طبيعة العمل في المشروع هذا
في الغالب تكون نائية
إذا كان هناك حلول نستطيع تنفيذها؛ بالعكس نرحب فيه
ولكن عملية مثل ما تفضل دورات المياه
وللا تعبية البنزين ضرورية لأداء العمل
يستطيع برضه أن ياكل وجبات خفيفة خلال الفترة
لأن حتى أعرف ليس بالضرورة في المشروع هذا
حتى في كيانات مكتبية
الإنسان يمارس عمله ثمان ساعات بشكل متواصل
ومعاه وجبة خفيفة، أو أحيانًا يقول لك أنا أفضّل آخذه بعد نهاية العمل
برضه أسئلة كثيرة جاءت على خصومات مستمرة
تجي على رواتب موظفي «سيف»
فإن كثر خيركم عطيتوهم رواتب على 6 آلاف
بس إذا هي بتجي دائمًا ناقصة
والموظف ماهو فاهم أيش سبب النقصان؛ ما استفاد
هو أنا قلت لك مصطلح قبل شوي، أن هناك علم فيه بعض الأحيان
ولكن يكون هناك محاولة، خلينا نقول، ممكن أن يتم التغاضي
النظام واضح
من خلال الجولات الميدانية اللي احنا نسويها
احنا عندنا زيارة للمنطقة الشمالية والمنطقة الجنوبية
والمنطقة الشرقية والمنطقة الغربية ووسط المملكة
كل سنة نتجول
وهذا الموضوع كان أحد المواضيع
ولكن اللي حاصل الآن الموظف يستطيع
أن يدخل على شهادة الراتب أو مسيّر الرواتب الخاص به
بشكل شهري ويشوف وين الخصميات
وأيش اللي حاصل وأيش اللي مو حاصل، هذا رقم واحد
رقم اثنين، تم شرح الخصميات
صحيح هناك خصميات
ولكن تسمح لي استخدم مثال حق إعلان عدم حضور
أنت بتقلبها علي
لا، أنت بعض الأحيان لما أنت تقول
أنا عندي ظرف صحي، وجبت شهادة مرضية معترف فيها
ترى ما يخصم عليك
إذا أنت أعطيت خبرك للإدارة الميدانية
بما يمكّنهم أنهم يجدون بديل؛ لا يخصم عليك
لأن لو تم قبول إجازتك لوجدنا بديل
لكن إذا ما حضرت للعمل ساعتين، وبعدين قلت ما أقدر أجي
فأنت يصير عندك خصمية الغياب
ويصير عندك الخصمية الجزائية اللي مبنية على تكرار المخالفات
لأن هناك لائحة جزاءات تنفيذية معتمدة لدينا
من قِبل وزارة الموارد البشرية والشؤون الاجتماعية
وهذا شيء مو بس غريب على «سيف»
كل منشأة لمن تحب
والموظفين يوقعون على معرفة اللائحة هذه
فهو يحصل خصم، ولكن الخصم لا يحصل إلا بعد استنفاذ الحلول
لأن بعد كذا بتضرر الشركة
الخصمية بتجي الشركة بسبب عدم وجود من يمثل الشركة
في الجهات الاستثمارية، المعهد المالي والأماكن هذه
حضور موظف لا يعتبر شيء ملزم بقدر ما هو عالنتائج
لأنه يقدر يؤدي عمله عن بُعد
إيه صحيح
بس في حالتكم أنتم العمل مربوط بحضوره
برضه من الأسئلة اللي تكررت موضوع
بيئة عمل موظفينكم في جدة «البلد»
أنتم ماسكين موقع جدة «البلد» صح؟ أو جدة التاريخية؟
صحيح
يقول حتى غرفة ما هو موفر لنا، غريب صراحة
احنا العمل قائم مع زملاء في جدة «البلد»
على أن يتم توفير المكان، لأن احنا ما عندنا استعداد
احنا ما عندنا مشكلة
أيش اللي يعيقكم؟
اللي يعيقنا المنشأة ما هي تبعنا، ما يُسمح للموضوع هذا
والنظام الآن عمل قائم مع وزارة الموارد بشكل شخصي لتحديد المسؤول
إذا أنت بتقول مزود الخدمة
إذا مزود الخدمة ما يسمح له صاحب المنشأة
فيه التعاقد بينكم وبين هذا العميل
مسؤولية توفير مكان استراحة أو دوام الحارس الأمن، على مين؟
هذا الذي غير واضح حسب التشريعات الموجودة حاليًّا
لأنه فيها، لأنه حتى لو كان مقدم الخدمة
مقدم الخدمة راح يحطها في تكاليفه أول ما يقدم العمل
بس يجب أن يكون نظام موجود؛ عشان يقبل العميل ويدفع
أو أن يكون ملزم العميل بتوفير مكان للموظفين
فهي العملية يستطيع أن يديرها العميل مع مزود الخدمة
إن وضع التشريع واضح
ويمكن اللي يعقّد الموضوع هنا برضه أن جدة «البلد»
من مواقع «اليونسكو»
صحيح
فهذه برضه تحط ضوابط إضافية
ليش أقول لك كنت ما أبغى أقول لك دبلوماسي
بس كنت متحفّظ، لأن ترى حتى زملاءنا في جدة «البلد»
يبغون يحافظون على هوية «اليونسكو»
فيقول لك لازم يكون فيها مواد معينة والكلام
فهو قاعد يدرس الموضوع الآن
هل هو يقدمها أو يسمح لنا احنا اللي نقدمها
ولكن أرجع وأقول، احنا نتكلم على دور «سيف» في القطاع
دور «سيف» في القطاع الآن نتخاطب مع المعنيين والجهات التشريعية
أن يجب توضيح الدور هذا للشركات الأخرى برضه مو بس لـ «سيف»
فيه واحد يقول، هل في أمل نشوف مخرجات شركة «سيف»
تساهم في الضبط المروري لتحسين تجربة الناس اللي تعاني مع المرور؟
مسألة قرار، الإمكانيات التقنية موجودة
الطاقة البشرية موجودة، التشريعات موجودة
متى ما رأى صاحب القرار أن العمل مناسب بالشكل هذا
كما قلت لك، احنا محفز
ما نبغى يكون رغبة عن صاحب القرار يؤدي العمل هذا
بس ما يلقى بديل، ما يلقى شخص أو كيان يقدم الخدمة هذه
فالتقنيات موجودة، حتى الرصد من خلال الدوريات كـ «سيف»
ممكن تقديمه الآن
هذا سؤال أتمنى صراحتك تقدر تتعامل معاه، يقول
منافسكم الأكبر والأقدم في المملكة
هو شركة «المجال» للخدمات الأمنية، أغلقتها بوابها، هل أنتم السبب؟
هل شركة «المجال» قفلت بوابها أو خرجت من السوق؟
أعتقد لسبب تشريعي، ما هو لسبب...
لسبب تشريعي؟
إيه
ما هو بسبب «سيف» أو حاجة مثل كذا
برضه منافسينك يشتكون، بيقولون كيف منافسة عادلة
وهم الوحيدين المسموح لهم بحمل السلاح
أنتم الوحيدين اللي عندكم رخصة حمل سلاح؟ موظفينكم؟
أنا بيعطيك أكبر دليل
إيه
أي شركة تعمل في النقل المؤتمن يجب أن تحمل سلاح
«سيف» أو غير «سيف»
غير النقل المؤتمن
غير النقل المؤتمن إذا اعتمدت وزارة الداخلية
الموقع أن يكون موقع حماية مسلّح
سيكون متوفر لسيف أو غير «سيف»
بس فيه سؤال صريح
هل فيه أحد غيركم عنده رخصة تحمل سلاح؟
طيب هو لازم على أساس نكون احنا دقيقين
لأن الجهات المختصة برضه لها رأي في الموضوع
أنا أسألك سؤال اليوم، هل يوجد موقع تم اعتماده من الجهات المختصة
تقدم فيه خدمة مسلحة؟
أنتم جاكم هذا الشي؟
مافي
هذا يفترض فرضية ماهي بدقيقة
ما في، لكن أنا ارجع وأقول لك قادرين احنا
ولكن أقول لك أيش اللي يثبت أن القطاع قادر؟
خدمات نقلهم ولا يحملون سلاح
سواءً في «سيف» او خارج «سيف»
أيش فلسفتكم في عدم توظيف كبار السن؟
هل لأنهم غير مناسبين، ولا غير مرحب فيهم، أيش الفكرة؟
بالعكس، أعتقد احنا قلنا المتوسط تسعة وعشرين
ترى اللي رفعه إلى تسعة وعشرين هو الكبار
بس ليش ما توظفون كبار السن؟
موجودين بالعكس
إذا متوسط الأعمار عندكم تسعة وعشرين، معناه أن...
بس أنت الحين لما تتكلم على توظيف كبار السن
أنت تتكلم عليه كبار السن من حيث عدم القدرة
سميته كبار سن وللا عمر؟
عمر
لأن إذا هو عدم قدرة فالسبب واضح اللياقة الطبية، فهو ما تجاوز
حتى أقول لك فحص السموم، بعض الأحيان ليس بالضرورة يكون سلبي
يكون بسبب تعاطيه لبعض الأدوية
الإنسان عنده قدرة، وبعدين ترجع تقول لك الشباب
في العمل الميداني يحتاج جاهزية جدًّا عالية
تحمل الجلد وتحمل الظروف البيئية وتحمل التعامل مع الجمهور
هل عندكم بدل خطر وبدل سلامة؟
هذا البدل يصرف للكيانات غير المتخصصة أمنيًّا
أنت لما تروح لكيان عمله مثلًا صناعي وعنده إدارة أمن؛ يُصرف له
بس احنا عملنا أمني بالكامل؛ فالبدل مصروف بشكل مباشر
السؤال قبل الأخير، موضوع البنات أو توظيف السيدات في قطاع الأمن
هل شايفينه فرصة؟ هل أنتم شغالين فيه؟ هل فيه مجال؟
بالعكس السيدات والعنصر النسائي
أعتقد كانوا منافس بشكل قوي
ونجحنا من خلال أدائهم أن نزيد حصتهم لدى عملاءنا
متواجدين معنا في الميدان
ولكن ما يُحد الموضوع هذا النسب المتعارف عليها
هناك نمو في النسبة
الحاجة الثانية، بيئات العمل
لما أنا أخلي إنسان يعمل في المنطقة نائية في سيارة بالشكل هذا
أنا ما عندي إساءة، إذا هم عندهم رغبة
ولكن أنا أحاول أبحث عن بيئة مناسبة
كم يمثلون كنسبة من موظفينكم؟
أنا عندي النسب، ولكن المشكلة أن النسب تتغير بشكل شهري
لا، بالعكس مو متوقع منك تكون حافظ الأرقام
3% ميدانيًّا، ولكن ترى في الإدارة الرئيسية تعدينا المستهدف
وأحب أضيف أن أول دورة نسائية لوسائل البحث الحية؛ تبدأ اليوم
بدون وأنت بكرامة وللا بكرامة؟
لا بالعكس، احنا نقول لك الكلاب، لأن زملاءنا يعملون في القطاع هذا
والآن نقدم دورة
عشان السادة المستمعين والمشاهدين بس يفهمون النكتة
لأن هي نكتة داخلية بيني وبينك
سولفنا أنا وياك في المكتب على موضوع الكلاب وأنت بكرامة
فانت قلت لا هذول يعتبرون... فيه حساسية في الموضوع هذا
أنا ما أقدر والله أقول على زميلي يعمل مع وسيلة بحث حية
أن وظيفته هذه غير لائقة
أنا أعتبر أنه بالعكس، أنا أقول هو يعمل
مع وسيلة تمكّنه من أداء عمله
والوسيلة هذه بالنسبة لنا مهمة
علاقة الاثنين، لما السائس مع الوسيلة جدًّا عالية
فهو يتعامل مع الوسيلة مع الكلاب البوليسية للرصد
بالعكس الله يقويهم ويعينهم
بس احنا كعُرف اجتماعي دارج
لما يجي طاري الكلب يقال وأنت بكرامة
أشكرك للإضاءة هذه
وفيه برضه جزء لطيف صار أو تفصيلة حلوة
أو توثيق حلو لهذا الموضوع للي مهتمي في برنامج «سين»
العام الماضي أعتقد كان فيه جزء من حلقة صندوق الاستثمارات العامة
كان فيه عن الوسائل الحية، كيف يتم تدريبها
وكيف كفاءتها في العملية الأمنية
فاللي مهتم ممكن يشوف الحلقة
صحيح ذكر فيها قطر والوسائل الحية ومركز التحكم، تم الظهور في...
هل بنشوفكم في المطارات؟
أخذتوا أي عقد في المطارات؟
والله يا عمر أنت، أنا ما أدري
هذه أسئلة الجمهور، ترى الجمهور واصل
ما ظنتي أنها أسئلة الجمهور
والله أسئلة الجمهور
فيه بعض المواضيع ما يشتغل عليها إلا بعدد معين داخل الشركة
احنا قلنا هنالك مشاريع أيقونية
فقلنا «إس تي سي» في 2021
كأس العالم 2022، استحواذ على «أبانا» 2023
2024 احتمال يكون الإجابة على سؤالك
أوه! ننتظر ونشوف
أنا بختم الأسئلة أبو سلمان يمكن نقول ملخص
احنا حديثنا كان عفوي، وتنقلنا من موضوع إلى موضوع
بشكل سلس وغير مقيد
ودي لو أبغى ألم القصة وأقفل فيها الحلقة
باختصار، أيش هي «سيف»؟ وليش جات للسوق؟
«سيف» هي ممكّن لخلق مسارات جديدة
وتغيير المنظومة بما يتناسب مع المستقبل
«سيف» سوف تقوم بخلق تكامل في الخدمات الأمنية
هنالك خدمات اليوم ما تعتبر أمنية
ولكن في بعض القطاعات تعتبر أمنية
«سيف» سوف تكون ممكّن للعاملين ومزودين الخدمة
والمشرعين والقطاعات الأخرى
«سيف» تحقق تكامل اليوم أفقي
مكافحة حرائق، إدارة مرافق، أمن
يمكن تكون تكامل عمودي، خدمات استشارية، وسائل بحث حية
والرحلة أنا أقول للزملاء القادم أجمل
الرحلة في بدايتها، ثلاث سنوات نعتبر نحن لسه في البداية
عساك بالقوة، شكرًا لك أبو سلمان على قبول الدعوة
شكرًا لك
شكرًا لكم، وشكرًا لفهدة القصير في إعداد وإنتاج هذه الحلقة
فؤاد الهتلان في الإخراج الإبداعي
ياسر بن غانم في إدارة التصوير
في الإضاءة إسماعيل شوقي
في تسجيل الصوت عبدالرزاق المزي
وفي التحرير أنس الخليل
وفي الهندسة الصوتية عبدالعزيز المزي
وفي إدارة الإنتاج عبدالمجيد عمر
وفي الإشراف على الإنتاج رزان الدهيثم
شكرًا للراعي الرسمي شركة «صفا»
هذا بودكاست سقراط
أحد منتجات شركة ثمانية للنشر والتوزيع